And links.
There's a cycle where the snowshoe hares get to a very high number and the links
eat them all and then the links get to a very high number and they run out of
snowshoe hares and the lynx dropped down again and the snowshoe hares come back
up.
This is the natural cycle and you're saying the cycle is going to be like a
Conor McGregor run rounds.
You're Brooklyn's there's always some come.
There's always someone.
There's always someone who writes,
who is the biggest draw right now in the UFC for sure.
This isn't a sinus because second,
besides,
besides him,
George Saint Pierre,
if he wants to fight George St Paul,
especially just wimpy Connor Brock,
George,
those are your three cash.
Brock would not be Conor at this stage.
One,
two,
three.
Right.
But if the UFC was around,
I mean if we were at the stage where Brock was like say before he beat Frank
Mir,
like when,
when when he was the heavyweight champion,
when Brock was just smashed,
he was a,
he could sell what was like the highest pay per view with Brock and I think it
was like 2 million to third highest honor in Nate's first.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's in that level.
And the UFC wasn't as popular then,
I don't think as it is now.
But they,
they did the dub dub,
he had the WWII fan base crossover.
But what's interesting to a lot of people don't,
you know there's a reason why,
but the demand for Nate Diaz too,
cause remember he's part of the biggest paper you of all time with Conor
Mcgregor.
So Nate Diaz in that tier two,
you can go Connor Brock,
Rhonda,
Nate's four or five and eight.
It's number two,
UFC 100 Brock Lesnar versus Frank Mir.
1,600,000 bucks.
That's a lot.
It's only 50,000 different than Nate Diaz versus Conor Mcgregor,
which is number one.
That's pretty crazy.
Those numbers are crazy.
So,
um,
and then Conor Mcgregor,
Nate Diaz,
Conor has one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
Misha Tate,
and I need it is amazing.
What UFC 200 so you had Brock Lesnar Chicago.
Yeah.
Brock has a shitload.
Brock has one,
two,
three out of the top seven and there it comes in at number eight.
They're in their own.
They're on their own stratosphere.
Right?
Like people want,
you know,
they don't toss them in there.
Nate's right there.
Yes.
Number one.
Number three,
that Amanda Nunez,
Ronda Rousey got a million million one.
Nate Diaz.
That's arguably because he was fighting Conor McGregor.
Right?
Well,
and that's why it hasn't taken a fight because that's the,
the,
that trilogy is the biggest one.
The biggest that hasn't,
yeah,
I mean it is the biggest,
it's the biggest.
If con,
here's the thing,
if Connor comes back and decides to fight Khabib,
that's a fight.
It's going to be a gigantic,
enormous,
biggest paper view of all time.
I think that's the benefit.
They decided to do it in Russia.
Fucking insane.
And I'll be watching from here with you guys.
We're doing a companion for this for sure.
Russia,
huck on the road,
and that'll be our biggest companion ever by the data.
Data's pulled me aside like two,
we're going to do some big things in Russia.
I'd really like you to come like could in that fuck outta here,
man.
I ain't going to Russia cut to me for around my face.
Eskimo.
So I it in Russia.
It's really amazing.
The problem is that trip,
that trip,
it's a long pass.
It's Cody here with you guys.
I'd rather be here with you guys anyway.
It's more fun.
It can be.
I really like being their life.
Don't get me wrong.
I love it.
I love the job,
but I'm going to be honest.
It's more fun watching the fights with you guys.
Yeah,
for sure.
Of course.
Just not even close to friends.
He didn't even clap.
We can get wine.
Yeah,
having cheese and kidding me.
Piss some people off because he chewing on the microphone.